I want you to imagine
that this is all the hooks
there is no machine learning there is no
AI there's just an island in the middle
of the ocean somewhere full of humans in
cubicles behind computer screens all
pretending to be AI
and when you send them some information
like a cat photograph
they quickly write cat and send it back
to you
if I gave you use of this resource for
almost free
what sorts of tasks would you send them
what would you have them do what
drudgery would you offload to them so
you wouldn't have to do it
as you're thinking through these tasks
you're coming up to the right
applications for machine learning
but wait
you don't know how drunk these people
are
please don't trust them blindly with
your important tasks make sure that
you're able to check whether they are
good enough at your task for it to be
okay to use them